it is now clear that Donald Trump's EPA
director Scott Pruett EPA of course
being the Environmental Protection
Agency is so corrupt and so dishonest
that he must resign and I've already
told you about Scott Pruett getting
access to this lobbyist really nice
condo for 50 bucks a night whenever he
needs it I've already told you about
Scott Pruett find a found in violation
of a whole number of different rules for
this $43,000 soundbooth that he had
built in his office I already told you
how he has been overspending on travel
as well as security and I've already
told you how there are at minimum ten
federal investigations into Scott
Pruitt's activity I've also told you
unrelated to any of this stuff that he's
terrible for the environment and that
actually I would tolerate some
corruption if I felt that Scott Pruett
was doing wonders for the environment
because I think that it's so important I
would allow a guy to maybe slightly
personally enrich himself in a corrupt
way if he's doing really great things
for the environment but he's not he's
not actually doing that but it's now
gone even further and there's really
nothing left for this pond-scum to do
but resign the Washington Post is now
reporting that last December
Scott Pruett went on a trip to Morocco
which was arranged by a lobbyist who's a
longtime friend of Pruitt's that had
received a $40,000 per month lobbying
contract with the Moroccan government
and what the Washington Post learned in
his reporting is that the trip cost over
$100,000 more than twice the number that
was previously reported it appears that
taxpayer money was used to pay for part
of the lobbyists friends travel expenses
which could potentially be illegal
Scott Pruett is the EPA director so the
immediate question is what the hell did
this trip have to do with protecting the
environment now they are saying the EPA
is saying that this was a trip to hammer
out a trade agreement and that Pruett
had just no idea that his longtime
friend was working for and being paid by
the Moroccan government actual ethics
experts are being crystal clear that
this is not common it's not common that
a lobbyist will be so involved in
arranging travel for the head of a
federal agency and there were also a lot
of last-minute schedule changes during
the trip which is unusual for
pterri level positions usually every
detail of the trip is figured out at
least weeks in advance and the only
thing that scott pruett did that might
even be tangentially related to his job
as EPA director is when he was in
Morocco he visited a solar power
research installation and he spent time
promoting imports from the United States
to Morocco of LNG liquefied natural gas
which is insane why is the EPA director
in Morocco shilling for private American
natural gas companies this is a guy
that's gotta go I'm having a hard time
thinking of anything that doesn't have a
tinge of corruption that Scott Pruett
has been involved in since he was
confirmed to this position to begin with
and once again there was never a plan to
drain the swamp it certainly hasn't
happened and Scott Pruett for me is at
the top of the list of the swamp filling
that is the exact opposite of what Trump
claimed to do who am I like who is even
close to rivaling Pruett in terms of man
filling there's no one worse there's no
there are more incompetent people and
there was positions but in terms of
doing a horrible thing for the country
and for the entire planet Scott Pruitt's
number one yeah like Betsy DeVos is more
notably incompetent than Pruett but it's
not I think it's not as much of a swamp
filling position it's a great definitely
cronyism but I don't know that it's a
swamp filler I think Trump could end up
firing him but he doesn't want to do it
right away yeah because then it would
seem as if he was coerced into doing so
by the media and all these reports he
wants to wait a little while the failing
fake news New York Times is reporting
about Scott Pruett and we're not gonna
let them take down our plan to make
America great again will anything come
of this or the 10 federal investigations
into Pruett well as Pat mentioned maybe
eventually Trump will sort of say it's
this is a good time for you go I wish I
had confidence that it would be dealt
with but I just don't have that
confidence and I know that there's lots
of people in our audience who also don't
and with good reason why would you have
that confidence because we've seen no
reason to believe that this type of a
swamp filling pond scum is actually
gonna be dealt with discuss this with us
on our subreddit david pakman.com slash
reddit quick break back after this
today's episode is
made possible in part by zipper ZPE our
banks and other financial institutions
are pretty conservative when it comes to
approving loans and the major problem
with this is not that they're being
cautious but that immigrants and
students and other disadvantaged groups
often don't have the requisite credit or
income to be approved Zippers goal is to
use smart contract technology and their
new cryptocurrency to provide a
revolutionary method of funding
transactions between borrowers and
lenders worldwide which would allow
people with no or little credit to
borrow currency through alternative
forms of verifying creditworthiness on
Zippers blockchain zippers initial coin
offering for their new cryptocurrency
starts April 16th if you're watching on
YouTube look in the description for a
link to their website and links to
information about their airdrop and
bounty programs this is not financial
advice and everybody should do their own
research